when do you really wish deep down inside  you did harry potter instead I got  unequivocally say no Oh probably a  better thing harry potter to and and you  know those films are excellent but um  they were shot over a very very long  period of time you know we shot lord of  the rings really over the course of 16  months and the better part of four years  but that was it harry potter what is  that a yes eight nine years yeah long  [ __ ] time night on in the new it's  eight films and then they've got the  whole backstory thing going on now with  eddie redmayne and your life yeah very  very long time and it was lovely to have  done it it existed in that period of  time and to have moved on I don't know  about doing something for eight years  Matt where you at with harry potter nice  piece of [ __ ] right now